[Music]
hey what's up
Samuel Leeds here and this week on
winners on a Wednesday we have mr. James
Armstrong we met when he was 19 I was 19
yeah you're now 21 yeah and you're
absolutely killing it in property so
congratulations thank you very much well
what what how did you how did you get
into property in the first place what
happened I met you at a networking event
and listened to you talk and thought
property sounds pretty awesome and then
you gave me your book and then I read
your book and then went through your
trainings than the crash course I've
done the DfE had done the Academy now
and yeah it's just all all thanks to
your training how did you how did you
afford to do all the training when we
met and you were like 19 how did you
manage to get the money well the crash
course is free that's correct and you
got a lot of value from that so much fun
I still go
I still go and is still possibly the
best two day course out there yeah then
the DfE I was able to pay for that out
of my income so sort of went on the
installment plan that was financed from
my work at the time and then I signed to
the Academy I got a loan for that yes
it's what's cheaper than getting a
student loan for go Travis have you have
you paid off all those loans and stuff
that you did for training I'm still
paying off some of them but I'm not
really first I'm kind of keeping my cash
to one side to invest it rather than
worrying about pain okay so you could
pay it off but you're choosing not to
yeah yeah that's cool that's cool how
much money are you now making through
property about four thousand pound
months about four thousand pound a month
you've quit your job yeah quit that back
in August that's cool Krauser so cool
so what were you doing then up until you
kind of went full-time into property I
was working as an electrician I picked
that up about two weeks after I stayed
and deciding I want to get into property
as a tie over to pay for my training the
idea was always I was going to quit that
once I was able to swap over the income
at the end of August all my companies
were incorporated and I was able to go
full-time and I had a deal selling from
then onwards and I remember when we went
on when you came at the crash course
that must have been what about 18 months
ago it was just over yo who's genuine
just over a year while I let you out at
13 months ago and I remember you said to
me I just don't want to be someone's
[ __ ] yeah I did I can't stand the idea
of being in a job where I'm working for
my house yeah you that really what was
it about having a job that you hate so
much you know I love the people I work
with it wasn't them I just didn't like
being in a position where I couldn't
call the shots and where I wasn't in
control of the hours I worked and the
times when I go on holiday yeah or even
how much I got paid you know I wanted to
I wanted more I thought I deserved more
so yeah I knew that for me and them I
needed to go self-employed so much has
changed in the last year so much so like
it's almost scary like now you know
you're always off skiing and you live
such a different life and you like had
money don't you oh I love spending money
I'm a natural spend like this I mean I
know you save him well which is great
but you know how to spend money well oh
yeah they're the fancy restaurants and
the holiday I'm a big fan of skiing I'm
a big fan of steak and neither of those
are cheap so yeah no that's great
so tell us then you came on the crash
course when did you because there's so
many different strategies that you need
property and one of the things that I
think you've done so successfully is
you've really focused because sometimes
people we call it chasing the shiny
penny yeah so you'll see our strategy
here oh my gosh that's great ah but this
is good oh that's a good course oh and
this is a good book and then what
happens is you try and do everything and
you lose focus and you end up doing
nothing what's been your strategy so I
wrote four deal sourcing okay I mean
with deal sourcing you have to learn
about all different strategies anyway
unless you just want to source HMOs but
I do bespoke sourcing so it's a case of
sitting down an investor and finding out
what's the best investment for them so
I've been through all the different
training so I know about all the
different types of strategies and after
doing that I thought well deal sourcing
is what I want to do it sounds like the
most fun allows you to get started with
no money so I went and I did deal
sourcing and yeah from then I've done
HMOs single let's rent to rent rent to
essays by refurbs now so kind of every
strategy but my strategy is deal
sourcing us so you'll say your income
that you're getting from property I know
it's a good income but it's active yeah
but why do you not mind it being active
because I love it to be honest and you
know people might go oh it's active or
it's passive but I earn like 4,000 per a
month and I do not do 40 hours a week
yeah you know you can earn that doing
like 10 hours a week and take your fire
of freedom challenge you in 8000
the week and probably didn't do 40 hours
worth of work to get that eight thousand
arguably I spent most of it cutting my
wig yeah yeah I know what you mean
so you're thinking fast pound stuff yeah
and then put that aside yeah interesting
what you said about how you've got debts
but you don't want to pay them off why
is that I don't seem as bad debts I know
I can pay them off pretty quickly if I
want to but for me say I'm going to take
paying 10% on a loan which is quite high
but it's am paying 10% on interest if I
could take that money and put it into a
property no twenty percent that's a
better return for me so I'm still making
ten percent yeah well if I pay off I'm
not making any money but that's a
completely new way of thinking it is
like but that is so an old school yeah
old school way of thinking is if you've
got a debt just pay off as fast as
possible all you're saying is I've got
debts but that's cool I could pay them
off like how much debts you have that's
probably about about nine thousand nine
about nine thousand mom you could pay
them off easy-peasy but you're not
because you'd rather invest that money
or spend that money yeah it's a really
interesting way of thinking yeah I'm not
too worried about it cuz I know I can
earn more and when you start a job like
this and when you change your mindset
you don't think oh I need to cut back
because I've got more bills coming
anything like that you go actually no
I'm gonna spend what I'm gonna spend if
I'm sure I just need to earn more yeah
so it's quite easy for the deal sauce to
go out find more deals and sell them
yeah it's kind of easing the same if
you're doing rents or essays or if
you're buying HMOs you just need to buy
another HMO or just get another rent to
us a deal and then that pays for the gap
that you've got I'm gonna talk to you in
a moment about how you find the deals
how you sell them how you grow your
investor list and all that kind of stuff
before I do that I know that you think
the deal packaging deal sourcing is
there most just the best way when we had
our one-to-one and when you join the
Academy you were like deal sourcing down
the line you want to be developmental
kinds of stuff but you you were so
focused why did you choose deal sourcing
and why do you think that rock so much
you I think because you're in charge of
your time is the first thing you're
really in charge of what goes on and the
second thing is because to be a deal
sorcerer you need to as I said already
to learn about all the different types
of strategies when you come to
invest yourself you know what's best for
you and yeah you can weigh up a good
deal on the bad deal for yourself yeah
that and the first thing I was sort of
heard you talk about was deal sourcing
and about how you're like a deal
sourcing machine that's where you
started and without it you wouldn't be
able to do what you do now yeah I
wouldn't be able to weigh up deals it
makes sense because if you think about
it like how long have you been on the
academy since June so what's seven
months seven months eight months
whatever it is so by the time you finish
the Academy after twelve months not only
will you have made a little money yeah
on maybe what 50 grand maybe more maybe
more but not only that but your
knowledge will be so so good oh yeah
because not only if you did all the
training but you've actually you've not
you've not bought anything yourself
necessarily maybe you will but you've
been packaging and selling so it's the
yeah you learn just as much is it yeah
it's not the best way to learn ever yeah
and my strategies well goes further than
that because I helped the investors with
all the refurb and with the conveyancing
everything like that so I've done all
the steps afterwards that you wouldn't
normally do as a deal sorcerer so I have
more houses although they're not in my
name
I've bought houses oh yeah I've managed
reefer projects we've got a number going
through as a kitchen going in today yeah
so yeah I've done all the stuff anyway
I've seen tenants go in so I've done the
whole thing so when I come to do it
exactly and with regards to the training
yeah Kevin 50k or whatever the figure is
my knowledge is worth way more than that
yeah so as a return investment ten grand
in for the Academy and I'd know 100 200
grands worth of knowledge way more
probably yeah you can just keep going
and keep making more money that's great
I love that tell me you then how do you
source the deals how do you know what
deals to source what kind of properties
have you been sourcing so start off with
HMOs standard HMO is very easy to find
when she's done the deal finding
extravaganza you spend a day doing this
and you I still like Rightmove still
like Zoopla and I go online I find
properties and I work out what my rents
are gonna be in the area I work out on
my rough house prices set the filters
and then just view every single property
and click on in the space of a minute
you'll know whether that's a good or not
that deal you well well yeah but I mean
say for example you look at room size
it's there normally she just scroll down
it doesn't matter
next one and after that when I book a
view with an agent
I'll always ask me if I've got anything
similar or what else they've got what
they've got
coming to the market that's not online
yeah so sort of I'm booking a viewing
for one anyway but I would say probably
temps at the time you get another
viewing just from booking the viewing on
the phone call because there's something
else that comes up so and that's some of
the best deals yet to agent stuff some
of the deals that come off of the agent
yeah off market but you've got in there
in the first place from an on market
deal yeah yeah okay so what so you go on
Rightmove Zoopla wherever all these
sites you find properties that look good
you go and view them and then while
you're viewing the problems is you might
not buy that but you then explain to the
agent what you're looking for and use it
as a get in the exact and then you start
getting off market deals from agents is
that yes main strategy yeah probably my
strategy I still have looking online
speaking with investors in the area one
time I was doing a property and the lady
was talking to me and just chatting
about it was to as a vendor viewing oh
yeah my brother's selling his house down
the road she goes moving off his talked
about after stewing around so I viewed
his house there and it's currently going
through that one now that might be a a
good refurb garage at this room for
development alongside it and i know you
tell everyone you're an investor oh yeah
tell everybody yeah absolutely
everybody's best way of finding sort of
new deals and because then people start
messages are you a property investor
like oh I'm off written selling actually
or we've got this problem so my
next-door neighbor and you start getting
leads okay so so specifically then now I
know you started with HMOs what what
what would be a good deal then because I
know there's a lot of sources out there
that are really crap right yeah you're
one of the exceptions you're one of the
few people who if someone goes on the
property investors with Samuel Leeds
Facebook page and says I'm looking for a
deal sorcerer I'll tag you I'll tag
Alastair it's probably three or four
people that I would vouch for and you're
one of those so what would be what is
the definition of a good deal well the
first ones it's all numbers it's all
figures it doesn't matter what it looks
like it really doesn't matter it's it's
just what so much is in how much is
coming out and what's my return on
investment but it varies because with a
rent to us a the ROI is gonna be high
it's gonna be really really good so I
thought that's more on cashflow the same
for rents around you for rent rent deals
making less than six hundred pound a
month I'm not interested yeah rental I
say probably about the same sort of
figure otherwise it's simply what are
the numbers are
is the rent reasonable have you spoken
to an agent to know if you're claiming
it's BMV is it actually BMV or is it
just below asking price it's so
important and that that great to me but
Bouguereau yes be envious be MVM like
was not yeah it's actually worth less
than what you've one of the interesting
things about you though James is a lot
of your business comes from repeat
doesn't it yeah yeah so you have the
same investors borrow from you again and
again you've been in this game now full
time for sort of six months and I know
that you've got one particular guy fact
there's a few who are almost like they
pay you serious retainers don't they
yeah they pay me monthly fees to manage
the portfolio but I mean I've systemized
it so I don't have to do much yeah but
yet they'll pay me a monthly fee just to
sort of get priority access to my deals
and they said I'm not talking 20 quid
it's a few hundred pounds like yeah and
and that they they want recurring deals
because they know the way I work but
equally I want them as investors because
they're easy to work with and I know
they're serious so you don't need
thousands of investors to get a really
good sort of monthly income yeah I don't
know I know tell me you your ideal
investor that you really love working
right I did investor as one that's got
probably somewhere around two hundred
thousand in the bank don't want to buy
more than one house don't want to buy
quick more important most importantly
there any button about numbers they
don't want to view it they're not fussed
about photos or condition or the
location it's will it rent yes okay how
much do you rent for right what's my
cash flow what's more or why how much
one he'd like to put yeah and that's it
they don't care yeah and you could hand
them a two million power source in fee
if the number four numbers worked out is
worth it they'd pay it yeah exactly I
mean the bottom line is if you find me a
house and it's worth two hundred
thousand but you find it for a hundred
thousand yeah I'm saving a hundred
thousand yeah I'm making a hundred
thousand my equity I'd be happy to give
you ten thousand for that so it's it's
all about the deal it's all about the
numbers so alright let me ask you a
couple of questions that I get quite a
lot and I'm sure you about to answer
while number one why would you not buy
the properties yourself if they're so
good
why wouldn't you buy them yourself I
have limited money I think most people
well everybody has a limited pot of cash
yeah you know people are rich but you
have a limited pot I'm funny on a lot of
deals I probably need in the region of a
million Panama
cash to buy every deal that comes
through that's a lot of money I don't
have that sort of money yeah
second thing is time buying a house it's
not a stressful process but it does take
time and if you've got when you've got a
number of houses going through the
moment you couldn't possibly do them all
by yourself it's a full-time job just
speaking with solicitors and arranging
mortgages you're so right
so doing that I I don't have time to do
all of it and yeah I would buy every
deal but I also know when I better deal
if it's making twenty five percent
return I know I can probably find forty
percent so I might hold out for a
slightly better one but you don't get
those all the time I mean 25 percent is
a great deal don't get me wrong
yeah and I would buy it but I also know
that because I can't buy every deal I'd
rather wait and so get the best ones
that totally makes sense and it's
interesting because I know there's some
people that come through the crash
course and they're not full-time deal
sources their investors first and
they're buying their own investors but
even their passing you're always going
to find a property deal that you can't
buy yourself yeah you know you can't buy
everything good that you find it might
not be in your area in your patch it
might not fit your strategy
it might be that you happen to already
have two properties going through and a
third one's just going to be too much
for you or do you not cash or you can't
get the mortgage on it or there's so
many reasons as to why I think it's good
to have that that that string to you by
the way it has properties on but what
you're doing really interesting is
you're it's not a string to your bow
this is your main thing my bow this your
bow but then I love the fact that that
your that's your bow at the moment but
in a year or two it might not be in the
year or two you might remember I've
saved up load of money I've had a load
of fun skiing and stuff I've got the
experience now I'm going to stop buying
some serious properties but when you get
to that stage the properties that you'll
be dangerous because the properties that
you'll be buying are going to be good oh
yeah they're all going really good but
what about that property that you just
found was yesterday yes I found out as a
buyer efer property in Liverpool rough
figures those got buy for about fifty
five thousand that's how much they want
for it I think we probably get for about
fifty it's worth eighty five when it's
done up it needs a new kitchen it needs
painting through our new carpets the
bathroom is a really good Nick and the
boilers brand new other than that
basically everything needs doing it's
about twelve thousand pound worth of
costs including about
thousand worth of contingency after you
paid your listeners fees and you stamp
duty everything else like that and you
refinance to the new value you leave in
about four thousand pound in and it so
you expecting to be able to port nearly
all of your money now nearly all of it
which basically what I'm leaving in is
my fees yeah and yet it's gonna be an
HMO it's gonna be for bet HMO it's in a
really good area and I'll supposed to a
an HMO manager the biggest one Liverpool
he's got an a charming every single
postcode and he knows that area goes
yeah that'll let out really well for bed
doesn't need to be licensed but it'll
still have fire doors everything else
that's including the cost and it's good
about five hundred fifty quid a month
which works so for fifty a month if you
put now what's the ROI on that like a
hundred and seventy percent one hundred
seven ounces that artists not even like
a controlling property yeah I can si see
those these kind of deals I mean I've
just I've just completed on one
yesterday I don't know if I told you but
it's very similar Condor figures they
are there why would somebody was I was
going to ask your question which kind of
sounds like a stupid question now even
though I get asked a lot and the
question is why would you pay someone to
find you a property that you could find
yourself especially as some of these
properties are coming from agents and
stuff like that one is on Rightmove so
what what would you what do you say to
someone that says why would I pay you
three thousand pound or whatever when
it's on write me if I could have just
found it myself
what's your response why haven't you
found it boom yeah that they're out
there you know and there's there's more
than one but do you want to go view them
let's be honest you could view ten of
those and I could all be crap you've
wasted a whole day yeah or you can find
ten they're already good you don't
really know until you go it depends how
much you value your time doesn't that
yeah you see I know a lot of your
investors are quite wealthy they might
know even a lot of you investors that
you live in England no they don't
they're from Dubai yeah all I can
eight-hour flight plus stoppages and
stuff together so it but time they've
got here they've had food pay for the
flights gone back home again just their
raw expenses a lot of times probably
more than three thousand yeah it just
makes sense to pay someone three grand
rather than coming down spending a day
viewing then the views cancelling which
a lot of them do yeah I had about three
or four cancel yesterday yeah there we
go messing around finding the builders
which you do yeah okay the quote
negotiating with the agent some people
would just say what the
so I just bought yesterday I actually
paid a saucy no porn an hour yeah I paid
Paul around yeah a sources fee and they
found the house but they know that area
I think we better than anybody else
better than I know the area yeah
so so uh I think well why wouldn't I pay
someone you know it's one of the things
happens with the Academy lot it's really
interesting
some people are passing by lying deal's
off each other yes Ellen deal sure that
deals to people in Academy yeah yeah and
it's easy to work with people neither
thing about the Academy there is
everybody knows what's a good deal as
well so I'm selling well yeah I can't
lie they've been on the training oh yeah
they know that as well I think anyone
that's watching this video I personally
think and you might disagree with me and
you might have a command or you that we
have an agenda
you could you could say that my agenda
of sale training courses you could argue
that you know that's not true
it doesn't come across and Emma feels
that way so I I don't honestly think
it's good that's true I don't think that
is it's it's really not it's been not
true all I think people should go on
training because I believe in education
and I think that a deal sorcerer could
can not you but a lot of them will pull
the wool over your eyes and sell your
bad deals yeah now I know I've saw them
they haven't all gone to plan not every
deal in property sometimes things go
wrong it's not about it's not about it's
not about did anything ever go wrong
it's about what did you then do how did
you fix it we thought things go wrong
yeah but there's some property sources
that sell bad properties for a quick fee
yeah run off with your money yeah and
and I always think that if you're going
to buy properties even if you're
planning on paying sources I still think
you should get the training because
otherwise people can pull the wool over
your eyes yeah I'll pay sources but I'm
coming from a position of knowledge I
know what's a good day oh no man pull
the wool over my eyes I know you deal
with people that are pretty competent
investors usually I hear I mean not
they're competent with money as well and
they understand stuff and they
understand wave figures work I mean you
build up a working relationship with
people so after you've done a few and
they get used to it though I think the
problem out might stop asking though I
definitely have seen them ask less
questions yes things goes on but then if
I have it would ruin my reputation and
I'd be done as a sorcerer if I started
selling crap deals in the space of two
weeks you could you could
lose everything yes start selling stuff
and you know might work when people are
happy they don't tend to say anything
yeah but when people are upset all the a
little world now oh yeah so you've only
got to upset one person yeah and then
you've outdone the ten good ones that
you did so it's it's a reputation thing
reputation is so important so let me ask
you a question
where and how do you find these
investors because you've said some of
them have come from the Academy that's
great but not all of them know Russ
majority haven't okay I've met a few
through Facebook I don't I have added a
lot of Facebook advertisement marketing
or anything like that I'm not very
salesy or anything that's just from
constantly adding value to people and
that's the first thing I'll say about
everything if you want someone to invest
with you you invest in them first by
giving them something of value if
there's loads of ways you can do that
you can give them a book you could I
don't know give him a free training
course you could give them some sort of
a free deal of what a collisional could
be anything
one-on-one a free correlation that's
kind of what I do is where you sit down
with them and go okay you've got 100,000
how an investor yes you could buy one
property in London but you can also do
this yeah get way high returns and that
usually works pretty well for me I've
found people that's my sort of niche
area in terms of my free gift the other
thing I'd say is just go out there tell
everybody what you're doing yeah that's
that's that's what really well for me
and I've met loads of friends and family
almost all people that I know of mmm we
don't know that well and then saves time
around go they've got like 100k in the
bank don't want to invest it hmm and
they come to you because you've told
them you're an investor you haven't even
gone I'm looking for investors I want to
sell deals to someone you just said you
just told if one knows what you're doing
cause you know yester and you're a deal
sorcerer so they come and they want to
chat to you about it and then the third
thing is just network I've done a lot of
networking I spent a lot of time
traveling across the country and so so
Peterborough Leeds Sheffield Manchester
Birmingham London and a lot networking
in London so what kind of networking
events do you go to property and
business related ones business is very
good
I find property related stuff in London
is very commercial and development
orientated so as a residential deal
source I don't have much competition in
outside of London there's a lot more
residential deal sources so the property
investing there as networking for
investors is slightly harder just got a
lot of people when to sell deals yeah
the business side of stuff like the BNI
things where it's not property related
specifically it's just business and
money orientated I suppose being able to
offer 20% returns or even 10 percent
returns blows people's mind yeah we're
trying someone guys like so you can get
like 14% no in yeah you could give me
14% I'm here in the house if you want to
own it then you get like 25 and he was
just blown away you thought that's not
even possible
yeah why it's amazing it's the thing is
though I mean when you learn the skills
to be in a good deal sorcerer he's so
valuable to people oh yeah it's so
valuable to people because one of the
best ways to make money is through
property when you like you do know how
to make money in property you know that
skill then the world is your oyster
yeah I'm all joint-venture with you yeah
we'll give you money I mean vest people
will pay you money to find them deals
it's just and you can help people
yes I've started helping a few sore
friends and family are in a fairly
tricky situations and as far as they're
concerned the only way of buying and
selling a house is just buying and
selling it there isn't any other way in
which you can do anything with the house
yeah I can go actually there's quite a
bit potential here and you can you can
really ease people's pain or like take
what they think is gonna be a hundred
grand building you knocking down to
about five thousand pounds because
you're able to reconfigure what they
want to do or how they want to buy the
house or something like that so yeah you
can really be really highly valuable to
people so yes they pay you lots for so
you can you can give back in a way that
sort of helps people out and you don't
want to fee from it because they're like
family yeah but it means the world to be
able to sort of see someone's life go
from really stressful really like sad
you know if you lose in your house it's
a it's not it's not an enjoyable
experience if you ever come in and step
in and help them out yeah yeah it's
nostrils yeah money comes when you add
value you add value to the motivated
sellers and then you get the deal you
had value to investors and then you get
it's all about adding value and then the
money follows yeah I mean dude you do
you probably you probably hear this a
lot and I know I'm young I'm a young guy
but you do not speak like a 21 year old
no I guess I don't I've your freaky 21
year old I've spent a lot of time
hanging out with people who aren't like
normal people
yeah and I would say if you want to you
want
kick ass in property or in any sort of
walk of life you need to be around
people who are kicking us yeah and so
true if I want to succeed in property I
need to sort of hang around and you do
down Russell and I'm one with the team a
lot in my every crash course I'm all the
training you're at every crash course
what you want we have a career the crash
course last weekend you were there this
weekend and the weekend after that and
the weekend after you I was gonna say
how'd you have the time but you've left
your job yeah you know and you can work
in and even yeah yeah okay I need to
call agents when they're open but I can
do what you do that when you come to the
crash course James as well you're not
like there with your own agenda you're
not there trying to sell your deals and
you're just there to be around
like-minded people yeah
let-let-let me and other successful
people rub off one yeah yeah you're
doing fantastic
yeah and pick good friends as well yeah
you've got a lot of good friends now I
know yeah I do in the academy and
outside of it as well
a couple of my two best mates for
example they they're not normal people
either yeah they're quite sort of clued
up they've got various friends that do
and family members a fairly wealthy and
I've done all sorts of different types
of investing and stuff but being able to
sort of use them then and get access to
their own family yeah whether it's
proper to your just business or whatever
it might be if people are successful
there's something about them that's made
them successful and the mindset in one
area of business often translates over
to another area absolutely it's the same
as me well I started out I was a
teenager and I just got put myself
people say you got lucky
no I put myself in the right place at
the right time
yeah and the right place is a property
event at seminars networking programs
that is the right place and the right
time is when you're ready to take action
yeah hundred percent you know so what
advice would you give someone then that
was watching this that was maybe in
their 20s they want to go into property
full-time they also hate their job yeah
what advice would you give to them ash
did a video on this and there's a few
things I'd say the first one is get
trained yeah you need training education
there's a number of books I can
recommend butter than that it's you need
to get trained and book started out for
me but to really get the in-depth
knowledge and to see it live get
yourself along to an event and the first
one I suggest as a crash course all day
long you don't have to go any further
but even the crash course is no
to see people sexist i know people been
on the winners on a wednesday or just on
the crash course yeah
so there's so much value in that and
then i would highly recommend Sanyal to
everything afterwards yeah the whole
thing just get on you and the and the
crash course as well sometimes people
think that it's going to be a two-day
sales pitch what's it like it's two days
of value in a high-energy yeah that's
what it is it's just awesome
yeah fine you can buy a product but it's
a class product you should be buying it
yeah absolutely man
what's next then for you James next
continue to solve source and build up
the sourcing so I've got more and more
deals going through every month to a
point where I'm at a point I need to
employ somebody or get a PA or someone
that's a help me out I don't think I'm
too far away from that then it's gonna
be as I am at the moment building up a
cash pot to invest I've got a number of
quite awesome investments which I
haven't actually put out so what
investors yet because I would sell like
that but I want them and I can see
what's coming up and I'm going okay we
can structure this and I can I get that
so it signs of a good property sorcerer
yeah I'll when it pains the property
sorcerer to let go over the deal yes
that means if the if the property source
is like yes I solve the deal then that's
not bad but when there's when the
property source is like oh I sold the
deal already don't want it that means
they're a good sorcerer yeah you know
said that's awesome
and then on to sort of developments yeah
and reefer projects I love buying refurb
and stuff your as well as making money
and getting a house quite cheap in the
end because it's you've refine its
forging money back out you're adding a
massive amounts of value to the
community you know your neighbors now
don't have a dog all next time of our
glorious house you brought the whole
street up in value sudden you're gonna
get better tenants and you're solving a
housing shortage in this country yeah so
you're doing a big service to the
community you know and you're getting
paid to do it yeah so I think it's I
love by referral stuff yeah I don't know
your faith is really important to you as
well massively massive ear alongside the
property mentoring I've just died some
spiritual mentoring as well right so
important yeah I think it's massively
important and it's helped me as well I
don't really get bogged down with lot of
stress and problems and things like that
but I so I don't really look faith for
me as an outlet for help but it's more
an opportunity to just make myself
better and to
more like doors open that I never would
have thought open if I I genuinely
thought that is a spiritual divine
influence that's allowed that's happened
so that's amazing bro I'm really good
what you're doing how would someone get
in touch with you if they want to reach
out to you I want to get on your deal
sourcing list so you'll get on the list
you gotta catch me first because I've
got to vet you I don't know if you're
serious I know you can a lot of people
get drunk to a list and that's great but
for me because it's bespoke and it yeah
it's specific I need to know that you're
a serious investor but I'm on I'm on
your Facebook page you'll find me on
there
I tell I'll put a link below to the
Facebook group yeah go to user property
investors with Samuel Leeds if you spoil
Academy you'll find me there at any
other course obviously come to a crash
course you'll find me there yeah I'm on
Facebook and all the rest of them so
just sort of search me there in the new
James Armstrong check him out find him
on Facebook bro you're amazing thanks
for coming on the show cheers right
thank you I hope you found that useful
guys we're gonna have another winner
next week so take action get yourself to
the crash course implementing their
knowledge and we'll see you next time
thanks so much thank you so much for
watching the video that is the reason
why I'm doing this your success is my
oxygen every single week we've got
people becoming financially free if
you'd like to see more success units you
can do that right here but what I'd
really suggest is why don't you come and
join us at the property investors crash
course comment on my guest completely
free and I'll personally be there for
two days to help you get started you can
see what happens right here what you'll
notice is all of these stories they all
start at the crash course so come along
my guests can't wait to see you there
peace out